the final specs of the iPhone 15 15 Pro
and 15 Ultra have been revealed and
there are multiple weird things that
Apple has never done before and analysts
are saying that the cameras are going to
be the stars of Apple September 12th
event and that it could be a pivotal
factor in getting people to upgrade now
each year I make a video comparing the
new iPhone against the previous two
generations and the upgrades are always
quite impressive and to be honest that
is why I upgrade my wife's phone every
year just for the better photos so we
can relive memories with our kids and
have the best shots possible but this
year seems to be an even bigger update
than usual we have this full spec sheet
right here and I'm gonna start out with
the iPhone 15 and 15 plus with the
iPhone 14 it pretty much inherited the
13 Pro's 12 megapixel main sensor and
that was a decent upgrade it got larger
but the 15s are getting a 48 megapixel
sensor and that is a huge jump in
resolution four times the pixels now you
might think it's the same camera that's
in the 14 pro but that is not the case
we are looking at a 48 megapixel F 1.6
aperture lens which is actually faster
or it lets in a more light than the one
in the iPhone 14 pro and the one that is
coming in the iPhone 15 Pro which is
really weird this is from minchi quo
saying that it is not the IMX 803 sensor
from the 14 pro and the 15 Pro but a
brand new one that is improved this is
using Sony's brand new two layer stacked
CMOS technology which is going to
improve the readout times give you
better dynamic range and better quality
overall now the ultra wide camera in the
15 and 15 plus is not going to change
it's going to stick with 12 megapixels
and same thing with the front but why in
the world is Apple using a brand new
great sensor that is better
technologically and has the F 1.6
aperture compared to F
1.78 in the 15 Pro typically you'd have
worse technology older technology in the
regular iPhone lineup well it seems like
this year Apple's taking a different
focus on the pro and the ultra and the
iPhone 16 is going to have an updated
main sensor now this might worry Pro
buyers but don't worry too much because
Apple will not let this phone do a
better job the sensor on it is going to
be smaller than the 48 megapixel on the
14 pro in 15 Pro if we look at this
example people right here the 15 and 15
plus is going to be somewhere in between
these two sensors so larger than the 13
Pro and the iPhone 14 and 14 plus but
not as large as the 14 Pros but the
sensor Size Doesn't Matter a ton when
you have improved technology with better
low light already what apple is likely
going to do is not allow it to save 48
megapixel images but only capture them
and bend them down to 12. this is what
happens with the iPhone 14 pro most of
the time unless you go and enable Apple
Pro raw and as you guys could see the
difference in quality is staggering if
you don't use that Pro raw feature and
the regular iPhones never get Pro raw at
all so you will not have the option to
be able to do that that means that
you're not going to get the full insane
detail from that sensor and you could
still have artifacts in the image from
the extra compression so even though the
camera is going to be a good Improvement
especially for cropping photos since we
don't have a telephoto lens in there you
will not get such drastic differences
like we see in this shot not being able
to save in 48 megapixel now the next
weird thing has to do with the 15 Pro
and the 15 Ultra we already talked about
the main sensor staying the same but the
telephoto sensor we have a 12.7
megapixel F 2.8 aperture now this is a
new sensor and that is great because
we've actually had the same 3x lens over
many Pro Models which is software tweaks
so this is going to be an update and
it's weird that they're bumping it up to
12.7 and the same sensor is going to be
used on the ultra but in a different way
now as far as the ultra wide that is
jumping to a 13.4 megapixel sensor which
is also very weird Apple stuck with 12
megapixel sensors for a very long time
and now we're getting a bump but a very
minor one so that ultrawide is going to
get better quality and it's weird that
apple is no longer keeping the sensors
the same so on this 15 Pro we're gonna
have a 12 in the front then you have a
12.7 a 13.4 and then a 48 all completely
different more like what you see on
Android phones now for the 15 Pro Max or
the 15 Ultra we are getting a periscope
lens and this is the most exciting part
for way too long I have Android Zoom
photos looked a lot better than the
iPhone Android phones have been using
these kind of lenses for a number of
years and it just works really really
well but the iPhone's gonna be better
it's gonna one-up most Android phones
because it's gonna have an optical zoom
that most phones do not have which means
that it can be a 3X for those times we
want to get zoomed in but not too close
and then it can zoom out to say 6X to
get you twice as close without ruining
quality like a real camera's zoom lens
does now one of the Sony is a very high
inexpensive one has a lens like this and
it is super cool this gives you the best
of both worlds with a ton of flexibility
without losing quality whereas on a lot
of Android phones for example the latest
pixel Pro you can do 5x but if you
choose to go four four and a half well
it has to crop from the main sensor and
the quality looks a lot worse and some
of the Samsungs were limited as well
where if you're not doing the full Zoom
well it just looks really bad and this
is a really great solution to that
allowing you to zoom in a ton but also
get really really good quality and still
not have to zoom a lot so we can go from
the 48 megapixel which can also do the
2x craft up which I personally love and
then you can have 3x all the way up to
6X and it's just gonna be awesome to
have that capability and then looking at
that leak again we have an F 2.8
aperture which is a lot better than some
of the Androids that are on the market
now what else could Apple do to make the
camera better and make it such a big
part of the show other than a really
nice zoom lens that not everybody cares
about well we had leaks previously about
the 14 pro getting 8K video but that
never happened even though that sensor
was 48 megapixels can technically do it
and Samsung has been giving us AK for
many years well with the a17 the better
efficiency Apple could easily give us 8K
that would rival Samsung's 8K which
they've had for many generations and
when it first came out with very slow
processors well it didn't look great but
over the years they've made it better
and the AK and the s23 ultra looks
really really really good still with a
much weaker processor than even the a16
now I believe that could happen because
they're now upping the base storage to
256 and that means people will be able
to fit those videos there and then with
that the other thing that they could do
is default the 48 megapixel main sensor
to actually save in heic or heif format
to get the full quality I showed you
guys how the file sizes are massive
shooting in Pro raw so I would go and I
would convert the files myself to make
them smaller and not take up a crazy
amount of space and this has been a huge
annoyance with the iPhone 14 pro but
with that extra storage and with the 15
and 15 plus getting 48 megapixels as far
as the sensor if they allow us to
natively shoot at 48 megapixel
compressed without those massive files
that would be a nice boost in quality
even though they are using the same
sensor so let me know what you guys
think about the full camera specs which
one are you going to buy if you're going
to buy a new iPhone 15 and do you want
to have 8K video capability like Samsung
has been giving us go ahead and click
that Circle above to subscribe check out
one of those great videos right over
there that's been Max and I'll see you
in the next one
foreign